extremely grateful for the enormous
outpouring of support and prayers
that the whole world and country have
been providing and sharing
i'd like to thank colonel andrew barr
and all the medical and support staff
here at walter reed
for their tireless efforts providing
everything and anything the medical team
the president and i could need this
morning the president is doing very well
behind me are some of the members of the
president's medical team
whom i'd like to introduce
dr sean dooley pulmonary critical care
dr brian garibaldi pulmonary critical
care
dr robert browning pulmonary critical
dr jason blaylock infectious disease
dr wes campbell infectious disease
dr john hodgson anesthesia
major kirk klein army nurse commander
megan nazworthy
navy nurse lieutenant juliana lavopa
navy nurse lieutenant lieutenant
commander john shea
clinical pharmacist and not present with
us our lieutenant beth carter
lieutenant maureen meehan both navy
nurses and dr jesse show now director of
our
executive medicine program as reported
yesterday
consultation with this group i
recommended we bring the president up to
walter reed
as a precautionary measure to provide
state-of-the-art monitoring and any care
that he may need
just 72 hours into the diagnosis now the
first week of covid and a particular day
7-10 are the most critical
in determining the likely course of this
illness
at this time the team and i are
extremely happy with the progress the
president has made
thursday he had a mild cough and some
nasal congestion and fatigue
all of which are now resolving and
improving at this time i'd like to bring
up dr dooley to discuss some of the
specifics of the president's care
thank you and good afternoon i'm dr sean
dooley as dr conley mentioned
i'll start off by uh mentioning what
what an incredible
uh how incredibly proud i am of our
medical team assembled behind me
uh and the honor it's been to care for
the the president over these last
uh 24 hours here at walter reed
he's receiving outstanding
multi-disciplinary
care the state of the science for
coronavirus infection
we are monitoring him very closely for
any evidence of complications from
either the coronavirus
illness or the therapies that we are
prescribing to
make him better we have monitored his
cardiac function
his kidney function his liver function
all of those
are normal and the president this
morning is not on oxygen
not having difficulty breathing or
walking around
the white house medical unit upstairs
he's in exceptionally good spirits and
in fact as we were completing our
multi-disciplinary rounds this morning
uh the quote he left us with was i feel
like i could walk out of here today and
that was a very encouraging
comment from the president moving
forward i'll go ahead and introduce dr
garabaldi who will talk about some of
our therapeutics
and the plan for plan of care for today
thank you
thank you dr dooley and i'd like to echo
the sentiment from the entire team what
a
honor and a privilege is to be part of
this multi-disciplinary unit to care for
the president
um about 48 hours ago the president
received
a special antibody therapy directed
against the coronavirus and we're
working very closely with the company to
monitor him
in terms of that outcome yesterday
evening he received his first dose of
ivory rem deserver
and our plan is to continue a five-day
treatment course for rem deserver
and the big plan for today since he's in
such great spirits and doing well is to
encourage him to eat
to drink to stay hydrated to be up out
of bed and to be working and doing the
thing
things that he needs to do to get well
and i'll refer dr connolly to any any
questions
thanks brian it's important to note the
president's been fever-free for over 24
hours
uh we remain cautiously optimistic um
but he's doing great
um with that oh one other note it should
be clear that uh he's got plenty of work
to get done from the chief of staff
and he's doing it um but that if there's
a couple questions about the president's
health
uh in the last couple days can you tell
us the president's
oxygen saturation levels yeah so the
last uh
saturation that we had up walking around
he was uh about 96 percent
and he's receiving he has not received
any supplemental oxygen he's not on
oxygen right now that's right
he's not received any at all he's he's
not needed anybody any uh
this morning today at all that's right
no he's
do you have an estimated date when he
might be discharged
uh well i don't want to put a hard date
on that
um he's doing so well but the
with a known course of the illness day
seven to ten we get really concerned
about the inflammatory phase phase two
um given that we provided some of these
uh
advanced therapy so early on the course
a little bit earlier than most of the
patients we know and follow
it's hard to tell where he is on that
course and so
every day we're evaluating does he need
to be here
what does he need and where is he going
what do you see is the probability that
he will need supplemental oxygen going
forward uh i don't want to put
a percentage on that but but right now
all indicators are that uh
uh that he'll remain off of oxygen going
forward
in terms of like blood clots pneumonia
bacterial infection what do you see is
the risk on that front
well we know that all of them are risks
associated with this condition
um uh he is receiving all of the
standard of care and beyond
per routine you know international
coveted protocols
so we're monitoring for all of that um
but at the moment there's no
cause for concern you said he was he's
fever-free now what was his fever when
he had one sir
uh i'd rather not give any specific
numbers but he but he did have a fever
uh thursday into friday and since friday
morning
he's had none okay what was the date on
top of the other
antibodies i'm sorry why doesn't here on
top of the antibodies
uh so remdezavir works a little bit
differently than the antibodies
we're maximizing uh all aspects
of his care attacking this virus you
know multi-prong
approach as the president i didn't want
to hold anything back
if there was any possibility that it
would add value to his care and
expedite his return um i wanted to take
it
and the team agreed and that's what we
proceeded doctor what was the date of
the president's last negative test
i'm not going to get into all the
testing going back
um but but he and all the staff routine
uh
routinely uh are tested um and so
doctor what is the ppe protocol for
president trump receiving visitors and
doctors it's the same as any hospital
has
we have an area that's uh that clean
that you you put your equipment on
and then beyond that everybody is fully
gowned up
masks gloves um we're protecting
ourselves and him
has have you done a screen has there's
been any sign of any lung damage
whatsoever
we are we are following all of that we
do daily ultrasounds we do daily lab
work
the team is tracking all of that has
there been any sign of damage i'm not
going to go into specifics of what the
findings are
down on one thing has he ever been on
supplemental oxygen
he right now he is not on i know you
keep saying right now
but should we read into the fact that he
had been preaching yesterday and today
he was not on oxygen
so he has not been on it during this his
coven treatment
he's he's not on oxygen right now has
hydroxychord
been considered as a vibrant treatment
option for the president we discussed it
he asked about it
uh he's not on it now and doctor what uh
symptoms has he also experienced
difficulty breathing
no no he has not never did a little
cough
he had the fever more than anything he's
felt run down
who is handling contact tracing is that
the white house or cdc
the the white house uh white house
medical unit in conjunction with uh
you know collaboration with cdc and
local state and health departments are
conducting all contact tracing for cdc
guidelines
when was the positive diagnosis made you
said 72 hours that would present
wednesday
yeah so thursday afternoon
following following the news of a closed
contact
is when we we repeated testing um and
given kind of clinical indications and a
little bit more concern
and that's when that late that night we
got the pcr confirmation that
he was is there any clarity on how he
became infected
not going to go into that as far as his
care it's irrelevant
or when he became infected yeah we're
not going to go into that
we're just tracking his clinical course
and providing the best care we can will
president trump have to stay at walter
reed to get uh the five day language for
your treatment
um we've discussed that right now uh if
he needs all five days
uh that will likely be the course but
again every day
we're reviewing with the team uh his
needs for being here
and uh and as soon as he gets to the
point where
uh it's not a requirement he may still
need some care but if we can provide
that downtown
at the house um then we will transition
at that point as long as it's
safe and appropriate the team agrees in
addition to his weight
does he have any other risk factors that
make him more at risk for sort of a
severe case
well not particularly i mean he's he's
he's male and he is slightly overweight
um other than that he's very healthy
his cholesterol is great his blood
pressure is great he's not on medication
for that
he's up and active you saw the his
activity the days leading up to
the long hours and everything else you
know he's able to handle it
can you provide other vitals like heart
rate blood pressure and temperature
um so his his heart rate is in the
70s the 80s his blood pressure has
remained
where it's where it's historically been
drawing our physicals
uh you know 110 to 120 stock he's great
it's never budged i've had no concerns
there so why was the decision made to
transfer him here
because he's the president of the united
states and obviously if doctors have
found that the prone position is helpful
for kobet has he been in that at all
no we actually he asked about that he
did thursday into friday
um he's been briefed by the task force
and all the scientists for months
and he brought that up you know as we
were discussing his cough
and at that time his oxygen levels were
okay we didn't feel like we needed to do
it
we came up here we discussed it with the
team as well we
consider all options but he has not
needed any of that well i wasn't the
first lady admitted as well
uh the first lady's doing great thanks
for asking she has no indication
for hospitalization advanced therapy
she's convalescing at home
uh thank you i'm gonna try to pin you
down one more time i know you said there
no office yeah yeah
yeah he's not on oxygen but did he uh
today and he didn't receive any on
thursday and he's
what's today saturday uh no no thursday
no thursday no friday or saturday that's
fine so that was why we were thursday no
oxygen
none at this moment yeah and yesterday
with the team
while we were all here he was not on
oxygen
so has the president actually been
admitted as a patient
to this hospital the president is a
patient
at walter reed national military medical
center is he on any steroids
thank you thank you very much thank you
foreign